when it comes to to my retirement in the  Aftercare  um man I I I have nothing but praise and  admiration for Veterans Affairs  um and I think that's important to say  and to highlight because once we you  know are done with our service  you know they are the ones that's taking  care of us you know medically  um sometimes even physically you know  when when you're in an accident or your  health uh  um  uh digresses you just you Veterans  Affairs is uh  probably the biggest institution that I  frequent  since I've been retired and they take  care of me wholeheartedly  um so I just wanted to give a shout out  to Veterans Affairs and all the  employees and the service members that  are serving with Veterans Affairs uh I  really appreciate you from the bottom of  my heart